il y a une réaction du chef de l'office
du président du bureau du président
André Irma qui est sur Twitter il a
simplement twitté quatre emojis d'avion
au dessus d'une photo avec son homologue
polonais donc c'est un signe de
satisfaction il n'a pas eu de réaction
directe pour l'instant de volodimeersky
mais vous l'avez mentionné ces avions de
combat réclamés par l'Ukraine et bien il
sont ils sont voulus par Kiev depuis des
mois en fait depuis le début de
l'invasion totale russe en février
dernier volodymer Zelenski martelait
qu'il avait besoin d'armes lourdes de
d'avions de combat alors c'est une
victoire évidemment que la Pologne a
décidé d'envoyer à leur au total une
douzaine d'avions 4 dans les prochains
jours et les autres lorsqu'ils seront
remis en en service mais évidemment qui
a fait ça que ce n'est qu'un début que
d'autres pays membres de l'OTAN lui
enverront promettront et ensuite environ
également des avions vous l'avez
mentionné les Américains qui n'y sont
qui ne sont pas encore arrivés à cette
décision les Anglais les Français ou
encore les Allemands en tout état de
cause ce ne sont pas ces quatre avions
qui vont forcément changer le cours de
la guerre mais comme l'Ukraine l'avait
exprès pour les chars de combat pour les
chars léopard la Pologne donne cette
première ce premier fait le premier pas
avec le crâne qui espère que les autres
alliés finiront par suivre